[Music]
[Applause]
the big news yesterday the uh
Indianapolis Colts went to the
Mothership to find their interim head
coach Jeff Saturday Dan orlovsky and an
analyst at the mothership joins us on
the program uh
where were you when you heard the news
and what was your reaction to Saturday
getting the job
uh I was on my way uh up to Bristol tsp
and I had gotten a little bit of a
inkling that something was going to
happen
um not necessarily knowing exactly what
but it was going to be big NFL news and
something unlike
we've experienced before of kind of
we've seen before and um you know Dan
like when the news broke
my initial thought was wow and then I
worked with Jeff two days a week you
know and I'm constantly in conversation
with them and my brain went back to all
the conversations that he and I have had
over the last like six weeks and in the
moment I didn't put two and two together
but as yesterday unfolded I was like oh
now it all makes sense you know we would
have these really detailed conversations
about what was going on in the NFL and
you know teams that were doing things
well teams that weren't doing things
well scheme
um philosophy identity coaching all that
stuff and you know kind of when the news
broke it made a lot more sense why and
and
um how we had those conversations but
why Jeff Saturday
why Jeff for the culture why Jeff you
know yeah
um I think the obvious thing is his
relationship with Jim irsay right the
the the he's got an emotional attachment
to the place
um they decided to move on from Frank
he's obviously been in conversations
about that role in some capacity you
know with them and or at least intimated
that he would be interested in it him
and ursay are close he's probably have
he's probably got pretty significant
back
from other uh notorious Cults as well I
mean Reggie Wayne is on their coaching
staff so I would imagine Reggie would be
somebody that would be stumping for Jeff
I would imagine Peyton did as well so
um you know the it the emotional
attachment I'm sure is part of this okay
but we talk about experience and paying
your dues and being a coordinator doing
all the grunt work Jeff played but now
you move to the head of the line and now
you're a head coach in the NFL how big
of a leap do you think that is for
somebody who has no prior head coaching
experience a massive I mean massive
we're talking you know going from
kindergarten to you know your freshman
year at Harvard you know it is a massive
leap
um I think the reality too Dan is you
know Jim Hurst this is the Assumption
game right he sat back with John fox
ex-nfl head coaches on staff and Gus
Bradley but Jim probably is sitting
there going there's I'm not hiring a
defensive minded person that would be my
guess okay right I the number one goal
is we're going to try to get as close to
the top of the draft as possible and we
we need to fix the quarterback situation
post Andrew Luck so everyone's saying
well not those guys why not those guys
with exit head coaching experience he
ain't gonna hire them guys like there's
no chance that he's gonna hire one of
those two that's my assumption so let's
give it to this guy who's an offensive
player all that stuff
um because it it may be he's he
surprises them and he keeps the job it's
a massive challenge though I mean he's
got to go because the players aren't
dumb either the players know a big
reason why he got that job is because of
his relationship with Mr irsay that
doesn't mean he won't be capable of it
um so he's it's a big adjustment it's a
big challenge for him to step in front
of that room
um and try to lead them through some you
know dark days of two months of football
left and trying to win and compete and
keep jobs
um and let alone not having anybody on
that step step was called place
you know that's they don't have somebody
Matt Ryan maybe Nick Foles but those are
the only two guys that have at least
some feeling for that
but now it's tricky he loves Jeff
Saturday he wants him to come in he
thinks he's the right guy but you just
said they're really preparing to be bad
so they can get a top draft pick and
finally get their quarterback yeah
I think that's a real thing for the
Colts I think I was on that 2011 team
um when they we ended up getting the
number one pick I think we went like two
and 14. no one remembers that everyone
remembers the fact that they got Andrew
Luck and then they had that run of years
and oh my gosh the Colts are going to be
great for the next 15 years I think Mr
irsay is sitting there going I need a
quarterback like I've tried to do the
whole really good roster and plug and
play the quarterback thing and it hasn't
worked and we know this class coming out
of college football is great so
um while I think it's a big challenge
for Jeff to try to go in there and win
football games I think irsay is
intrigued by who Jeff is and all the
traits into her skills that he believes
that a head coach has got to have and no
matter who he was going to hire or put
into that role the reality is that he
wants his quarterback and he wants to do
everything he can to to be in as good a
position as possible to go get that one
I'm wondering if we take all the
analysts at the mothership did Jeff
Saturday offer you a job to be the
quarterback's coach with the cult
uh not directly no not directly what
does that mean Dan
Jeff and I have had conversations about
coaching you know we've we've had some
really good
um really good in-depth conversations of
like
what coaching looks like
um what's the good who are the good ones
who are the bad ones
um you know my interest level in it uh
where I am in the present moment so I
think like Jeff was gathering again that
that's when I look back and I'm like aha
you know like I think he was gathering
kind of a feel and information without
revealing some of the stuff that was
going on behind the scenes
um I texted with them yesterday hey man
like good luck go crush it type of thing
um and we decided to touch base later so
no he he
um not directly offered me anything no
okay you're giving me a real answer here
yeah yeah
I mean I was kind of joking but you gave
me a real answer uh I appreciate that
will you Lobby
to join in this the cold staff
um no I won't Lobby you know I I um I I
I've made myself pretty clear to Jeff
you know my I love I want to coach one
day I'm very much so interested in it
candidly as the days go on and on I get
more and more interested in it
um you missed that part of football I
love what I get to do at ESPN right now
I love working for a guy like Jimmy
pitaro I love working with the people I
get to work with on a daily basis
um but if Jeff
um I have a lot of friends who are
coaches in the league they all know you
know we talk all the time so um they
know where I stand talking to Dan
orlovsky the former analyst for ESPN as
he gets ready to join the Colts coaching
staff how about I get all of the booger
I get swagu I get Rex Ryan Mina kimes
can come in as well and everybody would
be the number one one on the list
everybody comes in and joins the
coaching staff with the Colts how do you
think that uh that coaching staff would
be we wouldn't have the number one pick
then we would we would we would do too
well
um okay no uh you like we would have a
lot of fun right
um I don't know if everybody's ready for
that lifestyle You Know It uh but uh I
don't know if everybody's ready for it
to be criticized like we do on
television either
um okay a couple other things I'm
watching Lamar Jackson last night yeah
I don't know how he does it I don't
think there's a quarterback that's asked
to do more for his offense than he is
and he somehow
um it it's pretty remarkable they don't
have running backs they don't have wide
receivers he doesn't have his great
tight end and somehow he you know made
it work on the road yeah so the first
thing I'd say is if I were the Baltimore
Ravens there and he's healthy
I would not let obj out of my building
and or off the phone they they because I
think they're one of the like seven real
Super Bowl contenders stand real I think
there's a group of three and then a
group of four they're one of those seven
I think it's really hard to win the
Super Bowl now that Bateman has been
injured
I think it's really hard to do it
without one of those guys and if obj is
healthy and looks like in four five six
weeks he could be like a I don't I don't
know if we're gonna get obj playoff run
but like a darn good presence and player
man because that I I think this is one
of the scariest teams in heading into
the back stretch here they've they're
six and three and they haven't even
played a b game this year they've played
like mostly B minus C games they haven't
put one full game together Lamar is the
um I mean I the Allen Iverson of the NFL
you sit there and go how all the time
does he get that done you know and he's
such a competitive Talent he's last
night he was really good at playing warm
rather than playing hot you know a lot
of times quarterbacks when we're hot
meaning more guys are coming than we can
protect the ball's got to come out well
he played really warm meaning there's
bringing six and I only have six so
somebody's going to lose at some point
so get in the ball of his hands the
situation or Run game was really good
um he's a superstar you know like and
and he hasn't even played his a game yet
there this year Dan so like again it
once if and when that comes together for
Baltimore man they are going to be very
much so in the in the main picture at
the end yeah I agree with you I thought
they were my Dark Horse to go to the
Super Bowl but I thought they would have
some weapons I thought the defense would
be better they just got real Kwon Smith
so that certainly helps out uh the
situation in Buffalo with Josh Allen
yeah so the owner nerve if he was a
pitcher this would be a big deal how big
is it as a quarterback
naturally it's a big deal I mean that's
everything and we're halfway through the
season this is a team that thinks
they're going to be playing into
February and one of the things that
we've always felt as Josh has ascended
is if Buffalo has to play at home we
kind of saw it last year versus New
England like they're at a distinct
Advantage because of the arm strength
that he can spin it and cut it through
the wind so like you feel that that
takes away a little bit of their
advantage and then you're like well how
you know how much is this going to
impact his talent because one of his
Specialties and makes him indefensible
is how much he can aggressively push the
ball down field the hesitation I have to
like the overreaction potential is the
last throw of the game Sunday when 69
and a half 70 yards on the move to his
left now maybe that's adrenaline maybe
that's blood flow what's going to happen
if it settles down all that how's it a
couple days after so like while I'm like
initially concerned I can't get that
throw out of my mind and so so I I kind
of want to wait to see what the the
report is today to to really get a feel
for it but if it's something that is
real yeah that's massive massive to
Buffalo can you manage
your arm as a quarterback like a pitcher
might rely on a different pitch that he
can't go to as often if he's got you
know tendonitis or you know some kind of
injury in there but I don't know how you
do that as a quarterback yeah I think
you can yeah you manage it during the
week obviously and you're treated and
but in the game itself there's certain
throws you can and you know you will I
think that's hard Dan and I think it's
especially hard for him because if I was
going to tell you one thing that I guess
was a Josh Allen and I'm like flaw
setback drawback whatever he is wildly
competitive and sometimes that gets him
into trouble right and so
um I think it's really hard for him to
like tame his competitiveness when it's
the fourth quarter of a tie ball game
and he's got to throw a 17-yard
outbreaking row from one side to the
other and he's off his back foot like
he's gonna throw it as hard as he
possibly can because that's what he's
done for 20 or 20 years you know
um so I don't think that you could like
kind of reel in that wild stallion so to
speak in those moments great to talk to
you as always and we appreciate your
honesty and your insights
um but I do think coaching is in your
future uh which will be a big loss for
the mothership but I I could see that
see that happen thank you Dan thanks
brother that's Dan orlomsky football
analyst you can catch him on NFL live
weekdays at four Easter that escalated
I'm like uh yeah let me throw this out
there maybe uh the entire staff at ESPN
takes over is the coaching staff with
the Colts and then orlovsky talked about
wanting to be a coach and talking to
Saturday and I could certainly see him
as an offensive coordinator quarterbacks
coach uh you watch him when he's
diagramming plays when he and Ryan Clark
go at it offense defense it's great TV